follow me in the fire then don't run
into fire you want some answers Elsa and
we can't say we really blame you you're
so used to letting it go that you forgot
how important it is to get to the bottom
of things you're about to embark on a
wicked journey and your little sister
Anna isn't going to let you go alone I
won't let anything happen to her you
might find out some things you wish you
hadn't but just remember you're the
queen of arendelle and you've got a
kingdom to protect Anna and Elsa are
about to embark on the journey of a
lifetime and things are bound to get a
little crazy the brand-new frozen to
trailer just dropped and we now know
that the people of arendelle aren't
saved keep watching to find out what's
in store for Elsa Anna and the gang
bedtime stories the brand-new frozen to
trailer starts off with a bang
we see little Elsa and Anna being
cradled by their mother while their dad
tells them the story of his childhood he
goes into detail talking about an
enchanted forest and all the wonders it
used to hold we catch a glimpse of a
teenage Agner and what appears to be a
teenage I do not ignore describes the
forest as magical but then admits that
something went wrong since a ganar was
the rightful heir to arendelle we can
only assume that the late Queen Adina
was born and raised in the enchanted
forest which may be why she snuck out of
the bedroom midway through the storytime
with a morose look on her face what are
you hiding a Doudna the wind is calling
Elsa may be super gifted but she's
always seen her powers as a curse in
frozen Elsa sets off an eternal winter
by mistake and it looks like something
of the sorts is going down in frozen 2
in the trailer we see Anna asking
Kristoff pal
weird to you she seems like Elsa clearly
someone is calling out to Elsa from afar
and they want her to journey into the
unknown to find them
the wind is calling and it looks like
Elsa is the only one who can hear it
arendelle isn't safe anymore
whatever is calling to Elsa has ulterior
motives when no one else hears the voice
but her Elsa goes out to investigate and
that's when tragedy strikes we see a
burst I see Magic flow through Elsa but
it quickly turns malicious harsh winds
soar through the kingdom of arendelle
and pink flames unleash a wrath of
autumn leaves the people have earned
outrun scared and head for the hills
where they can seek refuge with the
trolls
grand pabbie sets Elsa on a quest find
who is calling to you they may have
answers but not before giving her a fair
warning of what's to come the kingdom is
not safe into the unknown if it were up
to her she would travel into the unknown
on her lonesome but her sister Anna
isn't about to let her out of her sight
grand pabbie tells Elsa that she must
follow the voice and find out the truth
prompting Elsa Anna and the entire gang
to journey north according to King Agner
the enchanted lands have been closed off
for decades meaning no one can go in or
out but also manages to disperse the fog
and enters the forest unharmed and
that's when things get interesting the
trapped civilization when Elsa and Anna
were young their dad told them about the
enchanted forest
and how something went terribly wrong
causing whoever remained to be trapped
inside of the forest forever we now
stand on across the mist they're
confronted by the trapped society and
they want some answers clearly no one
has been able to get in or out of the
forest since the mists first settled but
Elsa isn't just anyone so she defied the
odds this secret civilization has been
tormented by the enchanted forest for
far too long
and clearly Elsa Anna and the boys are
the only ones who can give them their
freedom what sisters are for
there's no use in denying it
Hana is her sister's keeper she's gone
through hell and back to save Elsa from
those who wish to harm her and now it
looks like she's going to have to save
her from herself
Elsa wants answers which can make her
too trusting on her quest to save
arendelle and Anna is tagging along to
make sure that Elsa makes it to the
finish line in the trailer we hear
outside Telangana that she shouldn't
have followed her into the fire don't
run into fire Anna would do anything for
Elsa because that's what sisters are for
taming a wild beast whoever is calling
out also wants to make sure that she
doesn't succeed in saving arendelle
mythical creatures are after Elsa and
Anna but Elsa isn't about to give up
Elsa has magical ice powers so we're not
too surprised to find out that she
chains the wild NOK that attacks her in
the ocean but will she be able to attain
the giant rock monsters - we guess we'll
have to wait and see something big is
coming for arendelle something big and
evil is coming to clean the kingdom of
arendelle and the people of the
Enchanted Forest are determined to stop
it at all costs a war is coming and also
as the key to stopping it frozen - is
going to be epic and despite everything
that may happen Elsa is finally going to
find out the truth about where she comes
from who do you think is the big bad a
frozen - sound off in the comments hit
that subscribe button to stay in the
loop and give this video a big thumbs up
while you're at it thanks for watching
we'll see you soon on the things
[Music]